Well, it's Halloween again and tonight our neighborhoods...
...will be full of all kinds of little ghosts, and goblins, and creatures of the night.
But have you ever wondered where those ideas came from?
Like so many of our celebrations,...
...the traditions of Halloween are deeply rooted in our past.
This all got started with the ancient Irish.
They celebrated the end of their pastoral year on October 31st.
They called this festival Samhain.
And they believe that on this night,...
...spirits came from the underworld and roamed the Earth.
When Christianity began to influence Irish tradition around the 6th century,...
...October 31st was made into a harvest festival, celebrating Saint Martin.
And the day after this was called All Saints' Day or All Hallows' Day.
So, the night before was Hallows' Eve or Halloween,...
...a combination of ancient Celtic or Irish lore, and a harvest festival.
I suppose the real symbol of Halloween these days is the jack-o'-lantern.
Its history is also Irish.
You see, there was this guy named Jack...
...and he had a terrible reputation for playing practical jokes on people.
When he died, he went to the underworld and he dared to play a trick on the devil.
The devil got so mad he kicked him out...
...and made him wander over the Earth at night with only the light of a lantern...
...to search for his lost soul.
Some say old Jack only had a pumpkin to carry his light in, hence the name jack-o'-lantern.
Now, we also have Jack to thank for the tradition of trick or treat...
...because he was such a trickster.
Have a safe and happy Halloween.
I'm Allen Smith.